hi I'm Erik Bosse and soloist our Wars
story answered all the questions we've
had about the galaxy's coolest scoundrel
how did Han get the name solo how did he
meet Chewbacca is space gas really a
spice look whatever you thought about
solo you cannot deny that this movie was
filled with connections to these Star
Wars universe many of them supersuit and
for me re watching the film to spot them
all gave me a whole new way to
appreciate it like sure it's solo but
it's also a Star Wars story and boys
have fun to discover how much of a stir
work story it is so let's go back
through solos scene by scene and find
all the stuff that you might have missed
the first time around and spoiler
warning for them move milkers who
clicked on this without seeing the movie
first so let's get started
the movie opens with no Star Wars
opening crawl and fanfare because like
rogue one it is a Star Wars story and
not a chapter of the main Skywalker
narrative and said we opened on Han
Solo's homeworld of Corellia Jung Han
played by Alden Ehrenreich steals this
m-68 land speeder gliding under an
imperial star destroyer as it's being
built along with TIE fighters under
construction all these factories and we
get our first nod at the past Star Wars
films Hans golden dice these lucky dice
were a set design edition from the very
first Star Wars hanging from the cockpit
of the Millennium Falcon recently in the
last Jedi the dice came back Luke
retrieved them from the Falcon and
brought them back to Leia and then they
faded away in kylos han along with the
rest of luke's force projection two
young runaway scavengers han passes brag
about getting extra portions for their
loot portions was how tiny amounts of
currency was described in the force
awakens one cost portion last week they
were a half portion when han runs into
Moloch he lies that he was just on his
way to see lady Proxima this echos the
moment when Han accidentally ran into
Greedo in Star Wars when Han faces lady
Proxima he threatens her with what he
says is a thermal detonator Leia used
one of those to threaten Java and Return
of the Jedi
now Han uses this rock shaped thermal
detonator to break a window and flood
the room with light allowing him to
escape in the stolen speeder and this
whole chase is very reminiscent of the
street chases in the movie American
Graffiti the success of which led George
Lucas to be able to make Star Wars Lucas
Harrison Ford and this movie's new
director Ron Howard all work together in
this movie escaping with
and is his lifelong friend Kira played
by Emilia Clarke from Game of Thrones
now the name Kira was actually the
original name of Rea back when it was
spelled K IRA
according to concept art for the force
awakens in the last Jedi during the
chase Han and his pursuers obliterate an
imperial ra7 protocol droid with one of
those dome helmet Imperial Navy officers
behind them both of which have appeared
in past films and a stormtrooper chases
Han on a swoop bike now I've seen those
show up in various Star Wars stories as
well and right before Han flips the
speeder sideways to squeeze through the
alley he confidently says watch this
this is something han says and Empire
Strikes Back right before he similarly
blows it oh yeah watch this in line at
the spaceport Kira makes his movies
first mention of the crimson dawn and
the Hutt cartel worried they'll get sold
into slavery to those groups cribs Adan
is the name of the crime organization
she later joined and Hutt cartel is of
course the group that Java is a part of
on Tatooine after breaking through Han
spots an imperial recruitment video a
cherina more upbeat version of John
Williams Imperial March this is the
first time in his Star Wars music has
been featured in a diegetic way in the
world of the story the recruitment
officer gives Han the name Solo and he's
off to min bong the swamp planet under
imperial attack we see new versions of
stormtroopers the mud troopers and an
80s T here han meets Tobias Beckett
Woody Harrelson and his partner vowel
tani Newton from West world and Ryo
Durant voiced by Jon Favreau who's
actually currently directing his own
Star Wars live-action series for Disney
han brags to Beckett that he was
boosting av21 s when he was 10 the av21
is actually a rare hand-built land
speeder that showed up in the game Star
Wars Galaxies he also tells the group
that he was kicked out of the Imperial
Academy this is parallel to Hans
original origin story from the legend
stories now we were actually supposed to
see what Han did to get kicked out with
the scene that showed Han escorted out
of a courtroom by Legends characters
tagging they were played by one of
the screenwriters of this movie Jon
Kasdan and assistant director Toby
hefferman but Ron Howard decided to
delete the scene Becket gets Han thrown
in a pit to get fed to a beast death
sequence it's very similar to the way
Java threw Luke in the rancor pit in
Return of the Jedi but this beast turns
out to be a friendly one
Han reveals that he can actually speak
the Wookiee language and enough
befriending Chewbacca and what seems
like a very brief courtship and it calls
him a mangy keshiki move milker which is
a nod to Hans line in the force awakens
move milker put a compressor on the
ignition line on the to escape and we
move on to van door where the team plots
their heist of the coaxial fuel from the
conveyux val is annoyed that they've
added Han and Chewie to their team and
she suggests that they recruit better
criminals like the zan sisters our boss
zan sisters refer to zu ins and pike
twin sisters from the book shadows of
the Empire they were affiliated with
Black Sun which is the same crime
organization that Maul interacted with
in Clone Wars and Bossk was the bounty
hunter from Empire Strikes Back and
Return of the Jedi
he's appeared throughout the animated
series and the games as well Beckett
reassures Val by promising that they're
gonna retire and return to glee anselm
that is his homeworld which came up in
legends as well and in Clone Wars he
also mentioned wanting to learn to play
the Valor chord that is a musical
instrument in the Star Wars universe
that's similar to a keyboard shows up in
aftermath during this whole campfire ryo
refers to my Knock roasts of aldra nia
my knocks were those critters in the EXO
gorath cave and Empire Strikes Back
apparently they are delicious
Chewie mentions the Empire enslaving the
Wookiees on Kashyyyk which was Chuy's
previous backstory and something that we
did see in Revenge of the Sith and in
the animated series we also learned the
origin of Hans blaster it was tossed to
him by Beckett during this conveyux
heist Ryo says that he wants to open a
cantina someplace warm his dream
retirement plan sounds a lot like the
cantina and Mo's Eisley on Tatooine this
conveyux heist is disrupted by emphasis
in the Marauders also known as the cloud
writers now the cloud riders is the name
of a group of bandits from the Marvel
Star Wars comics which sets them up in
this movie to be pretty bad dudes until
later when we learn what their true
motives are now this whole plan goes to
hell
Val and Ryo die and the tug-of-war over
the co axiom causes the loot to detonate
blow up a mountain
Beckett han and chewie head to the yacht
of dryden vas and the Crimson Don now I
explained what the crimson dawn is and
the meaning of their symbol over in my
video about the mall scene so go check
out that video
Dryden's Club features a dancing
Twilight girl
job I had one of those
and returning the Jedi you can also see
a servant with the top half of its head
missing these types are called D crane e
ated they're lobotomized Android slaves
that were originally going to appear in
robe 1 they're actually freak
experiments by dr. Eva's on that was the
a-hole plastic surgeon that Luke
scuffled with in Mos Eisley and he
showed up in robe 1 bumping into gin on
Jeddah Dryden's suite is littered with
Easter eggs among his collection are a
bunch of clues for the mall reveal later
there's a Sith holocron probably given
to him by Maul himself as well as a set
of Mandalorian armor with a red color
this could be a nod to the Death Watch
that's a group of Mandalorian Jedi
killers from the Clone Wars series some
of which wore red armor to show
allegiance to Maul fun detail here
there's also the golden fertility Idol
the one from Raiders of the Lost Ark and
speaking of Indiana Jones someone
pointed out that Crystal Skull which is
a reference but not Indiana Jones it's
from the Star Wars legends story han
Solo in The Lost Legacy Kira lists
possible locations of kalaxian including
scarf scarf was the name of the Imperial
vault planet from rogue one and they
realized unrefined Co axiom is on Kessel
which Dryden says is run by the Pyke's
the Pyke syndicate is another one of the
crime organizations from clone wars that
Maul interacts with but in order to pull
this off they need a fast ship which
brings them to Lando Calrissian played
by Donald Glover Hahn finds him the
middle of a game of sabacc
the gambling game which according to
legends Han did win the Falcon from
Lando but this particular game at this
point the movie is not the one that he
wins the Falcon and that comes at the
end of the movie and just to fill you in
because I think their names are stupid
and ridiculous the other players for
this table are Argus six eyes panics and
therms scissor punch now this is a
boxing was one of my favorites in the
movie it's like every line has some
meaningful subtext to notice the first
exchange between Han and Lando and the
street take nobodies in the sequence
Lando's responds foreshadows the way Han
will later take his seat as Captain the
Millennium Falcon Lando will later
vacate the captain's chair while he's
wounded in grieving l3 and then yeah han
takes the wheel from that point forward
claiming the Falcon as his and then as
they size each other up there is this
exchange so this is the back
hun is using the classic poker strategy
you know play the rookie act like you're
in over your head and then take
advantage of the people for
underestimated you but then notice what
Lando says ask you a question captain
Calrissian anything him
that's hot okay that's okay
Lando is deliberately mispronouncing
Hans name showing Han that he is on to
his accidental mispronouncing trick and
yeah you could also say this is
explaining the origin of Billy Dee
Williams as Lando saying Hans name like
this
Rajesh will find hat I promise and as
Lando sips drink he says this everything
you've heard about me is true and Han
will later repeat these words to Rey in
the force awakens verifying the whole
legend versus the man thing it's true
the force Jedi all of it
Lando also brags about having won a
subtropical moon on the OC on belts is a
reference to the legends novel Lando
Calrissian in the flame wind of ASEAN
where the asean system is known for its
wealthy inhabitants and tourism while
baiting Lando into betting the Falcon
Han says he pilots a vcx 100 that's a
reference to Star Wars rebels that's
actually the line of Starfighter that
ghost belongs to one of those also
showed up in row 1 after the game Lando
tells Kira that he assumed his debt was
settled with the crimson dawn after he
did the whole Felucia thing now Felucia
is the name of a colorful Outer Rim
jungle planet we actually saw it in
Revenge of the Sith that was where that
twilight Jedi Aayla Secura was executed
under all just 66 and then Beckett shows
up and Lando credits him as the guy who
killed
Horace sing Beckett says he pushed her
now or sing was an albino bounty hunter
who made a brief cameo in Phantom Menace
and she later played a much bigger role
in Clone Wars meanwhile over at the
Droid fighting ring we meet Lando's
temperamental droid l 337 voiced by
actress Phoebe Waller bridge now the
name L 337 is actually a reference to
late that was the old school computer
language and yeah the grimy ring master
is a cameo by Ron Howard's brother Clint
Howard he makes a cameo in all of ron
howard's movies as they head over to the
falcon l-3 snaps at Lando you couldn't
make it from here to Black's pyre
without me now that sounds like a
reference to the black spire outpost
that's the name of the upcoming Star
Wars themed section of the Disneyland
Park when l3 and Lando break
them into the shipyard and they come
upon the Millennium Falcon you can hear
a swell of John Williams main Star Wars
theme this is actually the first time it
plays during the movie and onboard the
Falcon l-3 complains that her circuits
are sticking telling Lando he's gonna
have to do that thing again later mm now
when asked about this moment the
screenwriters confirmed that Lando is
pansexual meaning he is not limited in
sexual choice with regard to sex or
gender or gender identity or in this
case human or droid while in hyperspace
Beckett and Chewbacca play the Falcons
holo chess game de jorik just like
Chewie will later do with Threepio in
the very first movie and a promo tour of
the Falcon before the movie came out
revealed that the vessel contains a
model of Cloud City for Orlando's future
colony Lando also has a closet just for
his many capes the scene between han and
kira here definitely echos the moment
Han cornered Leia on the Falcon and
nearly kissed her and Empire moving on
to Kessel the mining planet operated by
the Pyke syndicate now the disguise one
by Beckett should look familiar to you
this is the helmet and guard uniform
worn by Lando in the opening rescue
sequence from Java and Return of the
Jedi and the elevator shaft on the way
down the mines Chewie rips off a guy's
arm now this is delivering on a promise
that the movies made to us way back in
the first Star Wars nobody that's cause
a droid don't pull people's arms out of
their sockets when they lose now the
force awakens almost showed a version of
this with a deleted scene showing
Chewbacca ripping off unkar plutt Sarn
when Kira takes down a few of the pike
guards she tells l3 the martial art
style was Tara skocy
this is another big clue pointing to the
later reveal of Darth Maul at the end of
the movie teras kasi is the hand-to-hand
combat style from Star Wars legends and
Maul is one of the most well known
practitioners of it l3 removes a
restraining bolts from one of the droids
in the command center we saw Luke do
this to r2 in Star Wars
now the riot then Sue's allows Han and
the rest to escape with unrefined Co
axiom and among this chaos we can see a
bipedal dog droid and even though this
is the only Star Wars movie to not
future appearances from r2d2 and c3po we
do see a few astromech droids in the
style of r2 and an in-person cameo by
Threepio actor Anthony Daniels he is a
guy who helps to bakas wookie friend and
while the others are doing all this
grunt work Lando reclines on the Falcon
recording his memoirs he refers to his
time on Shirou which is a nod to another
Lando Legends novel Lando Calrissian in
the mind heart of Sheru
and as they load the quacks seem on the
ship notice how the camera lingers on
this hidden cargo hold this is the same
exact spot where Han Luke and shooing
the rest hide after the Falcon got
detained by the Death Star and later the
place where Rey and Finn hide from them
in the force awakens as they depart from
Kessel an imperial star destroyer blocks
their path and we see a swarm of the new
TIE fighters of this movie these are the
tie are bees or heavy TIE fighters known
for a more powerful laser cannon in an
extra pod this forces them to take a
dangerous shortcut through the already
dangerous Kessel run filling in the
backstory for the iconic line from the
first movie it's a ship that made the
Kessel run now the reason the Falcon was
supposedly able to do this isn't
necessarily its speed but its superior
navigational system and that's what's
really cool about solo we've learned
where this advanced navigation came from
l3 earlier in the movie Lando bragged
about El furries navigation database so
they upload her drive into the Falcons
computer basically endowing the Falcon
with El three's intelligence and
personality it could explain why han and
Lando have always referred to the vessel
as she and why c-3po has this reaction
the Falcon and Empire
so really l3 is to thank for honking
pleating the Kessel run in under 12
parsecs or rounded down at least and
right before he does he says I got a
really good feeling about this this is
the closest this movie gets to the
classic Star Wars line I have a bad
feeling about this and I guess it kind
of makes sense because Han is still
young and he's optimistic and he doesn't
really have bad feelings yet during this
sequence han loses the Falcons radar
dish
it's an odd day getting knocked off and
returning the Jedi a freaking dish never
stays on and we learned how the Falcon
loses that missing chunk of its nose
piece
han releases the escape pod Chewie also
reveals that he's 190 years old placing
his age around 230 during the events of
the force awakens of the last Jedi Han
also mentions an old buddy from Corellia
named needles who taught him a street
racing trick that actually led to
needles dying in a crash that sounds
like a reference to the Back to the
Future movies needles is a character who
challenges Marty McFly to a street race
that could have messed up
already pretty bad after outrunning the
TIE fighters they run into this massive
tentacled monster whose huge eye blinks
the further cockpit a similar moment
happens in the submarine and the fan of
menace and that there's always the
bigger fish sequence they lure the
monster into a giant gravity well called
the maw
now the MA is actually a detail from the
1994 novel Jedi search from the Jedi
Academy book series the crew escapes by
the skin of their teeth and we move on
to the dunes of Saverin
as han and Lando overlooked the wreckage
of the Falcon Lando says I hate you and
Han responds with the perfect callback I
guess it's a call for word technically
and then we see the return of the
Marauders an emphasis and Han steps up
to them with this awesome gunslinger
frame shot the closeup of his blaster
now the frame in here actually seems
like a specific omage to the shot in the
first Star Wars where Han comes up on
Jabba at the Falcon and Mos Eisley by
the way this is the original footage
with the stand in of Java that was
omitted from the original release
Lucas later digitally inserted Java and
included this scene in the special
edition now among these Marauders are a
few familiar faces one of them is
benthic two tubes he and his brother
were part of the partisan rebel group on
Jed ha that was group led by sagar era
and rogue one another is a cameo by
character actor Warwick Davis he has
made a cameo in pretty much every Star
Wars movie he actually could be the same
character that he played in the Phantom
Menace weasel that was the pod racing
spectator and business reveals the
Marauders are more than criminals and
killers they're actually a grassroots
gang of Robin Hood style protectors of
innocence at the crimson dawn terrorizes
they're one of the many groups scattered
across the galaxy that are gradually
leading to the rebellion and while Han
and the crew weigh whether to help them
Becket mentions a big shot gangster
putting together a crew on Tatooine is
of course referring to Java presumably
the deal that Han will get stuck in
leading up to the events of a new hope
they return to Dryden vos and Han pulls
a double switcheroo on him first
assuming that Dryden will think the
quack scene is fake han anticipating
Beckett betraying him and then tricking
him again with it actually being the
real stuff actually during the scene
Dryden offers them some seafood colo
claw fish this is a smaller sample of
the fish in Naboo that attacked qui-gon
and the others in that scene that I
mentioned earlier as Beckett leaves with
the KO axiom Dryden says you're making a
big mistake Beckett says it won't be
like first stride and says it will be
your last and then Beckett responds
maybe this could be a nod to the last
Jedi remember Benicio del Torres
character Dee
his final line as he took off with his
loot and maybe no no I guess is two of
them are pretty similar characters
they're morally ambiguous scoundrels who
put themselves before all else in the
melee that ensues we see Dryden's
weapons which actually look very similar
to those of the Praetorian Guard in the
last Jedi but I also think it's possible
that the dual bladed design of these
brass knuckles could be Dryden's way of
paying tribute to Darth Maul's dual
wield lightsaber actually get into all
of these Darth Maul clues plus the
significance of maules appearance in
this movie and his relationship to cure
in the crimson dawn all in my other
Darth Maul video go check that out
I explained the reference to the planet
Dafa Mir that he mentions and where if
you listen closely you can hear john
williams sneak in the duel the fates and
the score but in the final confrontation
between Hahn and Beckett it was nice to
see Hahn cut off Beckett's final
monologue by shooting first this brings
Han full circle with the deadly killer
that he was in the theatrical release of
Star Wars a guy who shot and killed
Greedo and didn't wait for great other
supers in the final scene han and chewie
catch up with Lando giving us the actual
legendary game of sabacc in which Han
won the Falcon during the scene Lando
mentions the StarCAVE nebula which is
another legends reference the book Lando
Calrissian in the star cave of don boca
and then after winning the hand Han
taunts Lando fair and square baby fair
and square giving us one last night of
the original trilogy remember you lost
her to me fair and square and as he and
Chewie commandeer the controls of the
Falcon heading to work for Java most
likely the movie closes with one final
shot of Hans lucky golden dice a
representation of the gambler who throws
caution to the wind and somehow usually
gets away with it but a question for you
guys which character in this movie do
you think was the most accurate to the
memory of the character Han Chewie
Orlando in general I think the act in
this movie is being a little unfairly
maligned and I liked all the
performances but really Chewbacca did
miss a beat I loved that walking carpet
I just want to take a nap curled up in
his lap comment down below with your
thoughts and tweet me directly at EA us
or falling rock stars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like and share
this video subscribe to do rock stars
for all of our Star Wars deep dives
though you know it's probably gonna be a
while since we got like a full year and
a half until episode 9 comes out until
then I guess I'll just wait for
adventure to call
[Music]
but are you putting into the sunset
binary sunset pop-up Baba bhai